foreign
so the most important thing to know
about anxiety straight out of the gate
is that it has gotten an unnecessarily
bad rap
as this happened for a lot of negative
emotions but you should know that
psychologists have long understood that
anxiety has both healthy forms and
unhealthy forms and a lot of the anxiety
we experience in the day-to-day is
healthy okay so what makes anxiety
healthy
anxiety is healthy when it is serving as
an alarm system that lets us know that
something's not right that it gets our
attention and helps us to keep ourselves
safe so if you're driving and somebody
swerves and cuts you off and you have a
surge of anxiety that's a good thing it
will focus your attention it will help
you be safe around that driver maybe
take evasive maneuvers but it's good for
you to respond if you're entirely
indifferent or relaxed in that setting
it's not as safe
so we look for anxiety to be of help to
us to guide us and to let us know what
we're supposed to be doing and not doing
I care for a lot of teenagers clinically
and you know I will say to them if you
walk into a party that you thought was
going to be a little get-together and it
turns out it's kind of you know wild and
you feel anxious pay attention to that
reaction like that's telling you
something that's indicating that you may
not be as safe as you thought you were
going to be
so that's healthy anxiety the only time
we consider anxiety to cross the line
from healthy to unhealthy is under two
conditions actually
one is when we have anxiety but there's
no threat that there's nothing wrong so
if it's you know a lovely Sunday morning
and you're taking a drive and there's no
traffic nearby you shouldn't be having
an anxiety response in that moment and
if you do we would consider that grounds
for concern
the other time we pay attention to
anxiety and consider it to be unhealthy
is if the anxiety response is way too
big for what's happened out of
proportion to events so if somebody
swerves and cuts you off and you have a
panic attack in that moment that is not
healthy anxiety it is not helping you
and we would address that clinically
other than that we really see anxiety as
largely normal protective healthy
and useful in our lives
okay all the same it feels terrible
right I mean I think one of the things
that's so true about anxiety is it
doesn't feel good even if it's actually
serving a useful purpose and so whether
the anxiety is healthy or unhealthy it's
really great to know how to get it in
check if you want to and that's what I'm
going to teach you now and you may be
surprised to hear me say oh let me just
teach you how to do this because our
experience of anxiety is that it's kind
of out of control that it sort of takes
over
but despite that the reality is that
anxiety is probably the most systematic
human emotion it unfolds in a very
stepwise fashion it's actually a one two
three process when it really goes off
the rails and so I'm going to walk you
through the one two three of how anxiety
unfolds for all of us and then we're
going to come back and I'm going to show
you how at every step of the way there
are things you can do to bring that
anxiety back under control
okay so the first thing that happens
when we have an anxiety response is our
bodies react there's actually just a
physical reaction that we have and it's
pretty Universal and it's very familiar
to all of us your heart rate accelerates
your breathing gets really quick and
shallow
um it feels uncomfortable there's other
stuff happening in our bodies too at the
same time but that activated heart that
kind of hyperventilating sense of
breathing everybody knows that feeling
okay what's Happening Here the
sympathetic nervous system which is the
part of our nervous system that is
paying attention to the environment is
sympathetic to what's around us
is kicking off some degree of the
fight-or-flight response right that
ancient response that we all know about
and in the fight-or-flight response what
we want to do is get ready to run or
attack and so our sympathetic nervous
system is taking measures to send a
whole lot of heavily oxygenated blood
out to our large muscle groups for that
purpose that's why the heart accelerates
that's why breathing changes and I you
know especially you know caring for
people who have not ever heard any of
this before it can be really helpful
um to understand that as strange as this
reaction is it has a sort of ancient
logic to it may not fit the moment but
it definitely makes sense and it's not
something going you know kind of out of
whack when our heart and our lungs
accelerate so that's the first thing
that happens the second thing that
happens is we notice that change in our
body and we come to the conclusion that
we're going to call it anxiety we decide
to use that label this is often an
arbitrary decision we can call it
something else but we can sometimes
default unhelpfully to calling it
anxiety
and then the third thing that happens
and this is where things really do go
off the rails is we engage in
catastrophic thinking and the definition
of catastrophic thinking is actually
very straightforward is when we
overestimate the risks and we
underestimate our ability to manage the
risks that's it okay so if you your body
reacts you're like I must be anxious oh
my gosh this situation is completely out
of control and there's nothing I can do
to stop it
that's when anxiety really becomes
miserable and that's the one two three
all right so knowing that let's go back
and hit every one of these in terms of
how we can work against them so the
first one the body reacting okay so one
of the most powerful ways to get the
body to calm down is through controlled
breathing
and I will tell you if you're having
like this really breathing like you're
gonna go to breathing I totally get it
for years I was like oh that's so
woo-woo that's not that technical it's
not that scientific okay I was wrong I
learned I was wrong and in fact
breathing is this really biological
intervention and what it does is it
kick-starts the parasympathetic part of
our nervous system and the
parasympathetic nervous system its job
is to reset the body to its resting
state okay here's how this works it's
kind of amazing so just as the brain can
signal to the heart and lungs like go
into overdrive you know we might have to
do something here
we're also of a mind that the lungs can
communicate back to the brain
so when we're anxious we're breathing
quickly and you know kind of shallowly
and if we override that if we
deliberately deepen and slow our
breathing what we think we're doing this
is sort of the understood science is
that we are hacking into a set of nerves
on the surface of our lungs that are
stretch receptors and all day every day
those nerves are paying attention to our
breathing to keep us safe and they
notice that we have slowed our breathing
and things have gotten calmer and they
read that as evidence of safety because
we only breathe deeply and slowly when
we're safe and they send that message up
to the brain saying uh you're kind of
having a reaction that doesn't make
sense because the nerves on the lungs
are telling us that we must be safe and
that's how anxiety comes under control
that's step one
step two if we want to need to is to
consider whether anxiety is the right
name for what's happening that um
we have a kind of activated response all
the time so it might be like you know I
was excited for this presentation and
before this presentation I kind of felt
a little bit of a REV I could have said
I must be anxious but instead I said no
I think I'm really excited and that
shift in thinking actually makes a huge
difference in terms of how we feel about
what we're engaging
the third thing we want to watch out for
is anxiety going off the rails with
catastrophic thinking and again that's
overestimating risk underestimating our
ability to handle it so if something is
feeling really really scary to you
really really anxiety provoking
key questions to ask yourself are am I
imagining this to be worse than it might
really be so you're going to try to
bring that estimation of risk down and
also do I have more say in how this is
going to go that I'm giving myself
credit for are there things I can do to
actually increase my sense of control
not feel as helpless as I do right now
so you're not trying to get rid of the
anxiety entirely but you're trying to
sort of get it in the narrower band of
not overestimating risk and not or
underestimating your own powers
okay so I'm going to start to wrap up
but here is the bottom line most of the
time we don't need to feel anxious about
feeling anxious it really is there to
help us out and whether we want it there
or not or whether it's helping us or not
if we want to get it under control
knowing the basics of how it unfolds
really does put you in the driver's seat
of knowing how to calm yourself when you
feel anxious and so you don't have to
feel like it's something that you are at
the mercy of
you spoke about breathing and uh you
know how you were skeptical in the early
days do you have a particular breathing
practice you like I do once I got over
my snobbery about breathing
I use something called Square breathing
or box breathing and you know most
people people have often heard of this
and it's really simple it's where you
breathe in on a count of three so one
two three and I'm actually going to walk
us through it as a group then you hold
it for a count of three one two three
then you exhale slowly on a count of
three one two three and then you wait
one two three so one two three in one
two three hold one two three exhale one
two three wait okay so let's all do it
together but here's my instruction to
you if you really want this to work
picture the nerves on the surface of
your lungs getting the message you're
not just breathing to breathe right
you're breathing because you are hacking
into this system and using those nerves
to communicate to your brain that
everything's okay all right so everybody
like blow up breath a little bit all
right ready breathe in slowly one two
three hold it one two three exhale
slowly one two three now pause one two
three that's it and you can do it a few
times if you're really anxious a lot you
should be practicing this when you're
not anxious so that you can slip right
into that Groove but it is powerful it
is really powerful and I am I'm a little
embarrassed about how long it took me to
get on the breathing training
I mean it's actually incredible because
just doing that with you you know the
little ball of uh whatever excitement in
my stomach just sort of dissipates
yeah
um so breathing people it's real it's
important uh so we already have some
questions flooding in and I want to make
this uh useful for the members so let's
get right to them
um first up uh Gordon wants to know
about helping other people how can we
help if we notice that a friend or a
family member is experiencing
um you know excessive anxiety
okay I love this question so the first
thing I would say just by being
generally useful is
we'll get to the excessive piece but
just
people need validation that anxiety
makes sense most of the time and one of
the real hazards of anxiety being talked
about as though it's everywhere and
always pathological is that people
experience normal anxiety and then they
think I'm having anxiety oh no there's
something really wrong
and so one quick thing you can do to say
somebody who's anxious if they're like
oh my gosh I have a big talk tomorrow
and I'm anxious you could say you're
having the right reaction that's really
like that's going to give you energy and
Juice there's nothing wrong with being
anxious about a talk or there's nothing
wrong with having to go tell your boss
something they don't want to hear and
that making you anxious that's
evidence that you work perfectly right
so that alone reassures people a lot and
then I think the next step you can do is
to say if it gets uneasy if it gets to
be too much more anxiety than is helpful
to you right even framing it is like
this should help you out until it
doesn't
you can actually dial it back so walk
them through why breathing Works
everybody knows they're supposed to
breathe very few people know why and so
that's why people won't do it and so
when I'm caring for people I will say
think about your anxiety being on a dial
right and if you're if it's a zero to
ten dial two to three you actually tend
to do a better job with whatever you're
needing to do if you have a little
energy a little ref once it gets into
four five six seven you start to be in
trouble and so I teach people to use the
breathing to actually turn down the dial
but that idea of like you're not at the
mercy of this you can be in the driver's
seat on this and you can re use
breathing or reframing or questioning
your own thinking is really helpful
because there is a general sense of like
we're hopeless in the face of anxiety
and we're really not so uh Katarina
describes an anxiety that leads them to
avoid uh things so meeting new people
because it's because it's scary do you
what do you recommend for that kind of
uh avoidance tactic around anxiety
oh Katarina I am so glad you brought up
avoidance this is actually the most
important thing we need to say when it
gets to talking about anxiety
so
when we're frightened of something
our instincts are like get away right at
least you know and if that is a tiger or
a bad driver those are really good
instincts and so when we remain
frightened of something that's in our
everyday lives we can actually feel very
compelled to avoid it
here is if you remember anything from
what we talked about today these are the
three words I want you to remember most
avoidance feeds anxiety
so here's the process it's actually a
wonderfully I think it's fascinating
science on this right so say Katarina
you're thinking about going to a party
like you've been invited to a party and
you're like okay I'm gonna I'm gonna try
to go to this party
and then um it's time to go to the party
and you feel your anxiety starting to
Bubble Up and you're like forget it I'm
Gonna Cancel okay here's what's gonna
happen you'll go from feeling very very
anxious to suddenly feeling much much
better
so this is the first helping of how
avoidance feeds anxiety which is that it
feels good they we call it a reinforcing
experience you feel bad you avoided you
feel better so you're like avoidance is
like kind of fun they're not fun but it
solves the problem
here comes the second helping because
you haven't gone to the party nothing
challenges your beliefs about how
frightening that party is
the party remains whatever you have
pictured in your mind you know people
not talking to you you know people you
know whatever like whatever you have
imagined about what makes that party
scary goes on challenge
if you actually go to the party
you often find it's a little bit there's
not a lot better than you expected but
if you don't go it remains very
frightening so that is how avoidance
actually entrenches anxiety over time it
feels good to do it and it actually
doesn't give us any competing data
so when you go see a clinician for
treatment of anxiety often we will start
by asking about what are you avoiding as
a result of your anxiety
and we will work with you on we call it
graduated exposure which is like
basically baby steps
getting you in there right so we'll say
okay could you go to a small thing with
a couple people right could you use your
breathing to make that bearable all
right and we would just sort of work you
into it very very slowly because the
solution to anxiety is often what we
call exposure you're making yourself do
it but you are not alone in this sense
of like
you know why not just not go it feels
better to not go and that's something
that we as clinicians work really really
hard on and I will tell you you know the
pandemic and kids and school you know
that and you know we've always known if
a child is frightened of school the
solution is get them to school even if
they sit in the teachers like you know
back office for the day physically being
at school is better than being home if
it's otherwise safe for them to be there
so another
uh area of anxiety that's that's popping
up in the chat
um is uh dealing with it in our sort of
children Robert wants to know what or
are there any differences between words
like anxiety and worry or fear as it
might pertain to how a teenager is
describing or trying to put a name to
um what they're feeling
I think it means to the kid whatever it
means but I will say teenagers use the
term anxiety a lot and they use it very
broadly
and I am
I've been practicing I've been
practicing for a very long time and then
in the last day I'd say 10 years I
started to notice like kids use this
term a lot
and I wasn't quite sure what to make of
it and then I was actually rereading
um Jane Eyre no it was Pride and
Prejudice Pride and Prejudice and um
Mrs Bennett I don't know if you remember
her she's like the kind of piece of work
Mom in that book there was a a line in
the book that was um whenever Mrs
Bennett was discontented she fancied
herself to be nervous
and I thought oh I think that's often
what I'm seeing with teenagers is
they'll say I feel anxious when they
usually mean not calm I don't feel calm
and so the first thing I would do if a
teenager says I feel anxious is to say
tell me what's going on
and they might say you know I've got a
big tryout tomorrow or you know um I'm
really this this concert is happening
that I'm going to with my friends and
listen for the possibility that it's
something besides anxiety it could be
they're excited they're amps they're
apprehensive so try to um
make more granular their description of
what is causing the stirred up feeling
and sometimes they are anxious and
that's when there's a threat right
they're like I'm feeling anxious because
I have my driver's test tomorrow and I
am not really ready that is anxiety
there is a threat they could fail that
driver's test right so listen for thread
and then if they do have anxiety you
know if they're anxious about something
they're like yeah well of course you're
anxious like that's kind of scary like
let's see what we can do to reduce your
sense of risk increase your sense of
control
but often it's very important that we
help them bring more Nuance to the
language they use around a sort of sense
of being stirred up and what's so nice
is that act of a teenager saying or a
kid saying I feel really anxious about
you know school tomorrow and you're like
let's make humans they're like your
classroom no kids like don't know where
things are going to be like and you say
yeah like
um you should feel apprehensive like
that is like there's a lot there and
also maybe a little excited if you can
get in there with words that are more
accurate than the big generic of anxiety
that act is in and of itself therapeutic
kids like yes I am apprehensive and also
excited right that they feel heard they
feel better and they have a better
language
so um
what I watch for especially
is kids saying I have anxiety
I like to say you're feeling anxious
because I think you know there is a
sense of like I have anxiety some I
think there's very much among
adolescents a sense of like
I have anxiety and what I try not to say
is well everybody has anxiety at some
level because I don't want to be
dismissive but to really help that make
that distinction between a feeling that
comes and goes and a diagnosis that they
would need to be concerned about
several folks want to know how can they
tell when to seek help when when anxiety
has become uh too crippling
um this is a great place to wrap up
right this is a perfect place to wrap up
so mostly this has been an ad for
anxiety like don't be frightened of it
be curious about it
trust that it's trying to tell you
something if it feels too uncomfortable
try these strategies to get it under
control
um but two conditions let's go back to
them if if you feel like your anxiety is
showing up and there's no reason like
there's no threat there's nothing to be
worried about that would be a great time
to seek out support but the other is if
your anxiety you're like well there is a
threat but like my anxiety is off the
charts and making me miserable or
getting in the way of my life that's a
good time to seek support so you know
pretty straightforward in terms of how
we Define what we consider concerning
but I really want you to know
um most anxiety does not need to make
you feel anxious about its own presence
[Music]